this is uh a very interesting voicemail
i received our voicemail number of
course is 2192 davidp
and you can call any time of day
here's a very specific question
about a story i have not covered and i
don't know that i will take a listen
david it's tommy
i'm coming to you with
tears in my eyes saying sir you must
check out
the 901 calls about lauren bauber's
family they're
perfect absolutely perfect
so
listen there is this story going on
where some 9-1-1 calls i believe it's
from radical repugnant reactionary
republican congresswoman lauren bobert
uh from her home
where her neighbor
called 9-1-1 because i guess bobert's
husband was going completely crazy and
like driving around and running over
people's mailboxes and just generally
acting
in a completely bizarre way
there are 911 calls that are out there
you know i don't have a problem
covering the personal lives of elected
officials
when it is relevant to policy like for
example when there is a hypocrisy
between their private lives and what
they espouse for example like on gay
marriage we've talked about this or when
there are double standards of different
kinds when we are talking about
criminality in their personal lives or
corruption i i have absolutely no
problem
the fact that bobert's personal life is
a mess and not only did her husband
previously expose himself to people
uh in a bar
all this we and now he's running over
mailboxes the guy seems to really have
some issues their relationship seems to
be
it just doesn't really seem super
relevant to the types of things i
generally cover on the show so i've
opted not to cover the 911 call story i
listened to some of the call over the
weekend
i don't know
i'm curious to hear from people in the
audience
is there a relevance to the story i mean
yes her personal life is out of control
yes i wouldn't trust her to watch my cat
and i don't even have a cat nor do i
even like cats i quite frankly i don't
think much of cats i still if i had one
or was in charge of one wouldn't allow
her to watch the cat all of that is true
i think the woman's a [ __ ] quite
frankly i just don't know that the 911
calls are really relevant to anything
that we talk about on this show but let
me know your thoughts we have a
fantastic bonus show today the situation
with salman rushdie being attacked
is truly truly a disgusting and
disturbing story and i've been a fan of
salman rushdies for a long time and
we're going to talk about it we're also
going to talk about how
when clinics that offer abortions
clothes
it's also a problem for what's called
gender affirming care and i'll talk to
you about the connection and the sort of
vicious cycle that exists and lastly ron
desantis has an idea
it's a terrible idea his idea is well
the teaching requirements are too rigid
in florida to become a real teacher
it's too strict
so let's figure out a way to allow
veterans with absolutely no teaching
experience or training or degrees to
allow them to teach school
and it's a very very bad idea which is
expected when you're talking about ron
desantis all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show pac-man's a loser
alex jones doesn't like it i know and we
will be doing a members only town hall
on wednesday august 31st which i hope
you will participate in and you can get
access to all of these things the bonus
show
the members only town hall etc by
signing up at joinpackman.com we will
see you on the bonus show or otherwise
back here tomorrow